bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat les beaux jours
sont revenus tout comme les touristes
deux ans après l'impact néfaste des
attentats de 2015 les voyants
touristiques sont de nouveau au vert
cependant malgré la présence de fleurons
du patrimoine français dans les yvelines
comme le domaine de versailles où la
ville de saint-germain-en-laye les
touristes s'attardera roman la nuit dans
notre département dont le nombre de
nuitées est l'un des plus faibles de la
région ile de france
pourquoi les touristes dans meute il pas
dans les yvelines quelle est la
stratégie pour booster ce secteur soumis
à une très forte concurrence pour
répondre à ces questions j'accueille
autour de moi philippe papin président
de l'uem et hd yvelines un syndicat
hôtelier et vous êtes également et du
modem au conseil municipal de versailles
et j'accueille également monsieur rené
frémy président de l'association les
bans des ambassadeurs qui défend les
intérêts des propriétaires de meublés
touristiques dans la ville de versailles
bonsoir à vous tous merci d'avoir
accepté cette invitation alors
versailles a un énorme patrimoine et
potentiel touristique
cependant selon les premiers chiffres
notamment du nombre de nuitées le
département bénéficie très très peu
justement à l'industrie hôtelière
comment ce qu'on peut expliquer cet état
de fait disons que la destination des
yvelines est particulièrement adapté
pour les familles et 80 % des touristes
dans les yvelines sont france lire il
faut le savoir ça c'est une donnée du 2
de l'office du tourisme départemental de
la mission tourisme qui n'est pas là
malheureusement ce soir est donc c'est
s'adresse en priorité face le public
c'est sont des franciliens en priorité
ensuite les touristes pur c'est vrai
qu'ils s'attardent plus à versailles et
au château et après seulement son moyen
de transport parce que c'est pas évident
se déplacer dans le département il peut
aussi après visiter france miniature ou
d'autres sites
ça veut dire qu'il ya un problème
notamment d'offre touristique c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya pas d'hôtel suffisamment
dédié aux familles mais quand celui-ci
fait pas un problème d'offre puisque les
des taux d'occupation que j'ai reçues il
n'ya pas longtemps sur les hôtels du
département sont pas son attrait ne sont
pas très haut
on parle de 60% noté aux 70 % maximum et
encore sur des hôtels de chaînes comme
puissance marketing quand même assez
énorme
donc non ce n'est pas anodin sa femme de
destination qu'est ce qu'on offre dans
les yvelines c'est ça en fait il fait
venir les touristes
qu'est ce qu'on offre en plus un terreau
natif du château donc c'est ce que je
pense le département va essayer de
développer dans les mois qui viennent
oui mais je rajouterais cependant qu' il
ya une partie des touristes à temps et
trouver ce étrangers plus
particulièrement ceux qui viennent
sud est asiatique qui en fait vieille
seulement vers sa ville il intéresse pas
particulièrement ils viennent seulement
versailles et parce que souvent
versailles plus nos destinations château
la loi aux chartes dans la journée donc
ils ne sont pas désireux de résider et
de prendre le temps de visiter de se
promener le connaître de comprendre
c'est une partie de la clientèle qui est
très importante je vis se promener sur
l'esplanade du château pourquoi et bien
sûr mais ensuite j'ai tendance à attirer
cette clientèle touristique
internationale qui viennent en bus ce
qu'ils essaient de faire l'europe en
deux trois jours ça touche tous les
départements mais pourtant le
département des yvelines au niveau de
nuitées très bon c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même un problème structurel dans
les yvelines
est ce que c'est parce que justement il
est trop bien relié au niveau ferrée par
rapport à parier que les personnes ne
s'attarde pas et aussi il faut voir on
est en concurrence avec qui avec le 77
où il ya dix n'écorne disney c'est une
grosse structure première premier site
visité notre messie tessin département
qui enregistre le meilleur taux de
nuitées pomme ile-de-france ensuite
c'est le 92 via le 91 et 1078 ensuite
dans l'ordre
donc s'il y avait une structure dans les
yvelines
il ya des projets touristiques de
structures du structurel qui soit décidé
oui je pense que là il y aurait à
l'appel et les touristes pourraient
parcourir le département ou plus il faut
pas non plus dire bon il ya un manque
d'hôtels mais pourquoi il donc d'hôtel
et ce qui est des projets est ce qu'il
ya deux ans je vous ai donné les taux de
dte les taux d'occupation et sont pas
fameux donc ça veut dire qu'il ya encore
de la marge
naturel il faut il faut je pense que
développer des projets il y en a
d'ailleurs je crois de la vallée de la
seine dont c'est un projet qui s'appelle
spot tourisme cdt en fait qui missionne
les lits chambre de commerce pour
développer des projets autour des
vallées de la vallée de la seine voilà
ça c'est un bon début et je pense qu'on
réussira à amener le touriste un peu
plus d'an département avec ce genre de
projet d'accord
cheikh hassan ben non je ne sais pas
exactement ce que c'est que le touriste
vous faites parce que vu de l'extérieur
dont monsieur te parle beaucoup mieux
physiquement et du d'extérieur le
tourisme c'est celui qu'il a soit pour
ce premier soit pour visiter
spécifiquement des lieux historiques
architecturaux ou même de très jolis
lieux comme les forêts mais le tourisme
de promenade en famille c'est parce que
c'est est en tout cas je vois pas très
bien monsieur pain et plus techniquement
mais je vois pas très bien ce que le
département peut faire pour ça parce que
comme il le rappelait il y à beaucoup
d'autres lieux en ile-de-france qui font
des propositions qui corresponde à ce
type de twins un autre projet aussi dans
le département c'est le fait que la
rénovation et la route la transformation
du château de la madeleine dans la
vallée de chevreuse quai dans le parc de
la vallée de chevreuse qui le pnr enfin
dangereuse c'est quelque chose de
formidable
ça c'est ça attire les marcheurs ça
attire les randonneurs
ça attire ces clientèles là car à l'aube
il y avait du potentiel du groupe
pourquoi est ce que aujourd'hui on est
vraiment bien structuré par accueillir
ces familles aujourd'hui est ce que par
exemple c'est possible pour des d'avoir
des sortes de comme on appelle ça déjà
les particuliers qui envoie maison
d'hôtes est ce que pour vous est ce que
c'est possible au genou et développer ce
genre dû être clientèle à nous les
exploitants et propriétaires doublé et
une clientèle qui est beaucoup plus
familial que celles que l'on trouve dans
virochem lui pour des raisons
économiques assez simple j'ai ainsi jour
de deux personnes plus deux ou trois
enfants sans un établissement hôtelier
ça revient beaucoup plus cher qu est ce
que nous offrons nous en plus nous
offrons à des personnes d'être reçus
dans des conditions de confort
normalement équivalentes à celles des
hôtels de catégorie à peu près que les
gens ce cas là pourquoi ce qui n'a pas
beaucoup plus grand domaine b
touristique pour cibler cette sa cliente
parce que
il se trouve que la ville de versailles
à juste titre a décidé de mettre en
place la réglementation issue alors je
vais pas vous citer tous les textes ça
doit leur être la réglementation issue
du code de l'urbanisme et du code de
tourisme et que cela fait un frein
puisque cette augmentation oblige à
acquitter de certaines compensations
pour pouvoir ouvrir un établissement de
cet ordre schématiquement pour vous il
ya un frein de versailles
il est logique changer de versailles
belgique c'est un autre frein me
semble-t-il il ya un autre frein c'est
que les gens qui viennent
averses versailles c'est pas tout les
yvelines qui met les gens qui viennent
de paris
nous notre clientèle n'est pas seul à
notre clientèle une clientèle familiale
un clientèle très importante de
professionnels qui sont en déplacement
professionnel c'est à dire que ils
viennent pour des réunions ils viennent
pour huit dix jours qu'un jour les
entreprises guyancourt où ils viennent
parfois en mutation pour six mois
c'est donc pas exactement ça nous permet
pas de savoir exactement s'il y a un
manque d'accueil touristique
il n'y a pas de france et une juste une
application de la loi le maire de 2014
et aussi de 2017 et de la précédente
2014 sur le code d'urbanisme
c'est le changement de destination c'est
tout ça pensez donc on prend une surface
pour en faire un meublé de tourisme donc
il faut qu'on ait un autre ont proposé
un autre à la location dite bourgeoise
parce qu'il ya un problème aussi là
c'est l'élue qui parle c'est la
désertification des quartiers par les
familles et dans le quartier saint louis
dont je m'occupe en tant qu'élu je peux
vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
meublés touristiques en a 700 sur
versailles
rien que pour elle airbnb et dans le
département près de 1700 2700 vous
pouvez multiplier par deux si vous
voulez avoir toutes les plateformes
facilement donc ça fait quand même un
joli paquet pour vous dit rien il ya
environ huit mille chambres
8000 9000 chambre dans le département
dont 1200 à versailles
donc voyez c'est quand même la moitié la
preuve de l'offre quand on signe le
furent ensuite les plateformes éviter
que il le type de clients qui reçoit
passé exactement les mêmes que des
hôtels de moyenne gamme comme le mien je
suis une telle deux étoiles
donc on a la même clientèle vous voyez
que la concurrence est pas mon réel
parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
contraintes
nous avons des commissions de sécurité
des commissions d'hygiène
on embauche il faut donc il ya tout un
travail autour du personnel du social
lire ci dessus donc c'est important
c'est très lourd et ça il ya pas mal
après qu'eurent ans vous avez ce pour
vous mais la même concurrence mais pas
avec les mêmes charges
on va les yeux alors il ya deux choses
la première est sa personne ni peu c'est
l'invasion de ce que l'on appelle des
plateformes et d'un terme générique et à
bint c'est une première chose deuxième
chose ils vont faire le distinguo entre
eux les appartements meublés de tourisme
et les chambres chez l'habitant
lorsque ces paris ce n'est pas ce qu'on
est moins cher que si ce monsieur parle
sans exacerber le problème c'est qu'il
n'ya que trois à 409 les touristes à
versailles le reste ce sont les sous
location de résidences principales et
sur la situation de ces résidences
principales
aucune municipalité n'a la main
la seule règle chez pas plus de 120
jours par an magie en fait c'est pas on
peut pas louer plus de 120 jours c'est
que dans la loi sru au considère que au
delà de 120 jours oui ce n'est plus
votre résidence principale puisque
saviez vous habiter ailleurs
donc c'est pas on interdit de louer de
tous se rassure c'est que c'est là que
le code de l'urbanisme qui dit que au
delà de cela joue en fait finalement
c'est plus votre résidence principale
d'accord donc effectivement mais quelque
part je comprends pas très bien c'est à
dire que vous vous dites qu'il n'ya pas
suffisamment d'offres que donc ça sert à
rien d'avoir des hôtes allemands même
temps il n'ya semblerait en
moment notamment pour justement ce genre
de plateforme avec des hébergements en
bas coûts oui parce que c'est
fiscalement intéressants ils n'ont pas
de charge les blogs et tous ici le yendo
n'ignore pas cette demande et on la
comprend totalement il n'y a pas de
problème là-dessus il n'y a pas de sujet
mais il faut remettre les choses en
place et qu'on dit qu'une concurrence
déloyale c'est parce qu'il est
effectivement ils n'ont pas les mêmes
charges que nous
fiscalement socialement et ainsi de
suite donc et voilà c'est tout après il
faut c'est bien d'avoir une diversité
dans l'offre touristique
nous on n'est pas contre ça sauf qu'il
faut faire attention et c'est là que la
loi le maire et la loi sur 2014 est
intervenu pour éviter la désertification
des quartiers et jeudi jeudi dans le 6e
arrondissement de paris vous avez 60 %
de l'offre qui dédié aux plateformes
d'hébergement touristique il ya soixante
mille appartements à paris
donc c'est énorme vous avez des des
quartiers qui se vide qui se vident et
des commerces qui ferment à cause de ça
à versailles ce n'est pas encore le cas
mais il faut pas c'est pour ça qu'on a
pris cette délibération c'est pas du
tout pour mettre un frein
si vous mais attention il ya des
fermetures d'écoles qui sont qui sont
peut-être un danger aussi si on laisse
se propager cette offre il ya aussi ce
côté la galette de côté c'est pour ça
que et bien justement quelles solutions
notamment pour pouvoir me répondent que
je maintiens qu'il faut faire le
distinguo notamment en matière de charge
et de concurrence parce que celui qui
sous une chambre au fond d'un couloir a
effectivement pas de charge mais le
propriétaire qui a acheté et
généralement sans et bien qu'ils ont été
rénovées qui a acheté 40 ou 50 mètres
carrés il a payé le prix du marché
il a investi 1000 à 1500 euros le mètre
carré
il doit bien amortir 1500 mètres carrés
de rénovation il faut bien qu ils
amortissent accordant le ménage fait par
l'opération du saint-esprit est dit
il fallait même dilemme contrainte cette
date exacte mais nous avons aussi des
charges
on peut pas dire que nous travaillons
sans change d'accord et mais nous ne
sommes pas véritablement contours au moi
je parle là pour les 300 ou 400 c'est
pas exactement tel les chiffres de
l'appartement meublé d'un versailles
pour les 804 lits nba que solutions
justement pour faire face à développer
l'offre touristique tout en forme il
faut bien fermer la demande parce que
moi je constate qu'il ya des demandes
familiales qui sont sans doute pas
satisfaites
quant aux demandes de personnes qui
cherchent le plus bas coût pour un
service dont la qualité n'est pas pour
important effectivement ils sont en
concurrence directe avec l'hôtellerie de
moyenne gamme et là moi je n'ai pas de
solution et je maintiens qu'il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui en l'état d'été qu'il n'y a
pas de solution puisque le seul contrôle
c'est le contrôle du nombre de nuitées
et en plus se contrôler
nous l'avons nous oblige cette heure
nous l'avons délégué aux plates formes
ce qui n'a pas permis et bim a perdu
donc fort à 20%
c'est pour ça que au niveau de la loi
est longue qui va être votée bientôt y
lire à l'article 51 qui stipule
justement du côté du logeur une
transparence au niveau du nombre de
nuitées est au niveau de la plate forme
une transparence au niveau des flux
financiers ingénieur pour effectivement
qu'une fiscalité qui s'instaure
paisiblement on va dire mais qui
s'instaure pour que l'effort que les
communes font pour le tourisme et à
travers l'office du tourisme a aussi
partagé par tous ce sera le mot de la
fin merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté de débattre et de
proposer vos idées
alors quand à vous je vous invite à
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet à la partager sur les réseaux
sociaux je vous souhaite une agréable
soirée à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]